in December of 2022 a Boeing trip 7
operated by United Airlines took off
from Hawaii in heavy rain in about a
minute into the flight the aircraft
plummeted towards the ocean it came just
750 ft from hitting the water at high
speed which almost certainly would have
killed all 280 people on board in the
end the pilots saved the aircraft by
just a matter of seconds now for more
than two months no one heard about this
incident it was as if it had never
happened and by the time the Main Street
news reports began appearing in February
more than two months later United
assured the public that the FAA had been
notified and that an investigation would
be forthcoming
watch all righty scary moments like this
though for some passengers on a United
flight out of Hawaii just moments after
takeoff the plane took a steep nose dive
coming within 800 ft of the ocean's
surface this happened December 18th
flight tracking data shows the Boeing
Tri 7 took off from Maui in a huge storm
you can see there climbed at 2200 ft
then descended at 8,600 ft per minute
towards the water a passenger told CNN
it felt like a roller coaster and that
people were screaming on board oh my
goodness the pilots yeah the pilots
recovered from the nose dive and then
safely made the trip to San Francisco
United says a formal report was filed
with the FAA the pilots then received
additional training the whole incident
lasted around 45
seconds that's a long flight after
something like that happens on takeout
takeoff now notice how there there's not
much curiosity from the news anchor
there about why this incident took so
long for the airline to disclose to the
public is the kind of thing that you'd
like to think we'd hear about right
right away and there's also not much of
an explanation about what happened
exactly it's implied that the pilots may
have made a mistake because they're
getting more training but what mistake
did they make exactly well late last
year we got something of an official
answer it turns out that according to
the NTSB the captain called for the
flaps to be retracted to the 5° setting
which is a normal setting for takeoff
but the first officer thought the
captain had called for a 15 degree
setting so he selected that one which
was the wrong one and that
misunderstanding caused a major problem
because the plane was going far too fast
for that flap setting to avoid damaging
the plane the captain started to slow
the aircraft while he tried to diagnose
the problem instead of realizing his
mistake the first officer suggested that
maybe the instruments were
malfunctioning and the two pilots
continued to kind of troubleshoot the
problem in the process they became
disoriented as the plane quickly lost
altitude the pilots confusion continued
until the plane blared an alarm telling
them that they were about to die if they
didn't apply maximum power and pull up
and they did and uh and unfortunately
nobody was harmed incredibly both Pilots
of the flight are still employed by
United Airlines we're told they nearly
killed everybody on board through their
incompetence but that's not
disqualifying apparently Beyond some
basic information about their flying
experience we still don't know much
about those two pilots for example we
know that the first officer has a total
of 5,300 hours of flying experience
which is respectable for his position
but at the time of the incident he only
had 120 hours in the Boeing Triple 7 and
according to a report by Tucker Carlson
last year which cited an anonymous
source at United shortly after this near
catastrophe took place this first
officer was a new hire at the airline
could that lack of experience have
played role and more to the point could
either of the pilots
identities have played a role in their
hiring or the airlines refusal to
terminate them after they almost steered
a passenger jet into the
ocean we don't know we're not allowed to
know because the federal government and
the airlines don't want us to know any
more information about the identity of
these Pilots or any of their pilots who
are involved in near disasters or
anything else about what actually
happened there is an ongoing information
blackout about these these kinds of
events and it's it's
deliberate but in their various public
statements and press releases United
Airlines has made it very clear that
they are mainly interested in hiring
pilots on the basis of skin color and
gender rather than competence in fact
they participated in a vice documentary
back in
2022 um United did about their Dei
initiatives uh watch so we are in a
plane right now I'm about to take off
with a student from United's new ad8
Academy bit nervous but let's do
this purey is training to become a pilot
with United Airlines which became the
first major airline to launch its own
flight school at the beginning of this
year but United is making another push
it said half of its recruits are going
to be women or people of color a pretty
ambitious goal for airline pilots who
are 93% white and 95% male black women
make up less than 1% of the pilot
industry
I have a confession guys I have never
seen a black woman fly a plane what made
you want to become a pilot so I was a
flight attendant for 3 years at a major
US Airline and absolutely loved it so a
couple years ago United decided that 50%
of its new pilot recruits are going to
be women or people of color and they're
promoting flight attendant to make that
happen later on in that Vice documentary
it suggested that the the point of this
initiative is to alleviate the pilot
shortage well how is that going a few
days ago the conservative commentator
Ashley stclair posed a few questions to
United based on some information that
she had received and and here's what she
wrote quote on July 29th the United
plane was nearly totaled after a hard
Landing who was flying that aircraft was
the co-pilot a former flight attendant
who was fired and then rehired through
United's Dei program despite being on a
list to not return to United am I
correct that this individual failed
multiple trainings including simulator
training am I also correct that United
has covered up this Dei disaster and
many
others that's the question she posed
again from based on Insider information
that she had received now United didn't
reply which you may have noticed is
something of a pattern uh no one thinks
we deserve to know anything about what's
going on in the cockpits of the planes
that we are flying in you're just
supposed to assume that everything's
fine and that the flight attendants are
transforming into Master Pilots at
United's Training Academy but the more
you look into the specifics of United's
diversity
initiatives the less solid that
assumption seems to be it turns out that
United partners with several
historically black colleges and
universities or HBCU as a way of
recruiting Pilots one of the popular
statistics focused accounts on X which
uses the name IO notice that two of the
schools that United has decided to team
up with which is Delaware States and
Elizabeth City State University are
quote in the bottom 2% of all
undergraduate institutions in the United
States the bottom 2% is where they're
finding their pilots Elizabeth State the
account noted uh quote had the
distinction in 1980s of being the only
University in which the average SAT Math
score was lower than that score which
would have been produced if a person had
guessed B on all multiple choice
questions on the
test that's a pretty sobering reality
especially if you plan on flying United
anytime soon now to be fair to United
they don't just recruit from HBCU with
no standards uh as a writer who goes by
the pseudonym pichy Keenan found United
also recruits from an organization
called Sisters of the Skies yes that is
an organization that sends Pilots to
United Airlines and their acronym is
literally
SOS at least you can rest assured that
they have a a sense of humor at United
as your plane is plummeting to the
ground maybe that will give you a little
bit of a laugh um and it gets better
watch J Williamson always dreamed of
sitting in the cockpit and calling the
shots what I like about flying
is I like you get to see different
things you never seen but that dream of
a career in aviation is a rare one for
black girls to accomplish with fewer
than 1% of Pilots women of color it was
tough I won't lie because there was no
one that looked like me now Captain
Teresa Clayborn is part of a group of
trailblazing black women pilots hoping
to increase those numbers we believe if
they see it they can be she was the
first black female pilot in the US Air
Force and is president of Sisters of the
Skies she is now a United Airlines pilot
why do you think more black women are
becoming Pilots it's extremely expensive
I mean it takes upwards of $100,000 to
get your licensing to fly so if our
young ladies are not seeing it if their
parents don't have the funding for it
then there're it's not going to
happen well that's inspirational if they
can see it they can be it you know
that's the kind of thing if you're in a
if you're flying in a plane you know
that that's that's that's what you want
out of your pilot to know that uh well
they they saw it at least that's the
qualification that they they that they
uh fall into that they they saw it and
they became it um now again this is an
organization that's training the pilots
that are flying commercial aircraft and
this isn't training really it's it's
like a kindergarten
classroom with these with these vapid
self-help slogans and inspirational
slogans at no point are these people
concerned about safety or competence
they want to put black women in the
cockpit because they want to inspire
more black women and that makes them
feel good um not because they they think
they're getting smarter or better Pilots
because if you want to get smarter
better Pilots then that's all you're
concerned with you just go looking for
pilots who fit these qualifications
regardless of what they look like if
they happen to be a black woman then
great if it ends up that you have no
black women pilots then that that is
also great because if you're just hiring
and recruiting based on Merit then
whoever's in there is the best for the
job and it's fantastic well what's a
better New Year's resolution than
building a daily habit of prayer
meditation prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being Hollow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the US it's
helped me maintain a daily prayer
routine and it can help you as well
download the app for free at hall.com
Walsh you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress along the way not
sure where to start we'll check out
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year
available on the Hallow app for brief
daily readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim cisel and
even some worldclass athletes with
hallow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using Hall to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
ultimately we'll learn how we can become
better individuals in spite of today's
broken world as we strive to become more
like Christ in our daily lives through
prayer fasting and giving download
hallow at hall.com Walsh and get an
exclusive three months free that's three
months absolutely free at hall.com
Walsh and this is not just some PR stunt
United is actually falling through on
this according to United's latest
corporate diversity report of the 51
students that graduated from United's
first class of Pilots quote nearly 80%
were women or people of color so they
vastly exceeded their target of 50% and
you can just decide for yourself whether
they got to that 80% figure because they
happen it just so happened that all of
the most qualified almost all the most
qualified people were women or people of
color I mean you you if you believe that
then fine they've almost completely
eliminated uh white men in their
training classes and and we're led to
believe that this is
progress meanwhile pay no attention to
the planes plummeting towards the ocean
or smashing into the runway which is
happening right
now to be clear this is a problem that
extends far beyond United Airlines I
mean they're maybe the most vocal about
their Dei practices but every airline
does this a few years ago in February of
2019 an Amazon air cargo plane a Boeing
767 operated by a contractor called
Atlas Air plummeted into the Trinity Bay
near Houston um now what was the reason
for that crash well the first officer
Conrad ASA accidentally pressed the
button giving the playing a massive jolt
and thrust which pitched the nose up and
instead of reacting calmly to the
situation as trained good Pilots are
supposed to do he panicked and he forced
the control column all the way down the
plane broke through the clouds and
disintegrated on impact with the water
now Conrad ASA never should have been
flying that plane prior to joining Atlas
Air in Amazon he had worked for seven
different airlines where he developed a
reputation for pressing random buttons
in emergency
he would always panic in the simulator
and just lose all situational awareness
and start pressing buttons but Airlines
kept putting him in the cockpit anyway
and that's why in its final report on
the crash the NTSB cited quote systemic
deficiencies in the aviation industry's
selection and performance measurement
practices which failed to address the
first officer's aptitude related
deficiencies and maladaptive stress
response now what explains those
systemic deficiencies
well we can't say for sure we do know
that Conrad ASA was born in the
Caribbean nation of Antigua uh he was a
black man which certainly checks some
diversity boxes and we also know that
Atlas A's website is full of platitudes
about the importance of hiring
candidates based on certain
characteristics like their race and
gender so we can come to some
unauthorized theories here about why
Conrad ASA was flying that plane and
none of them are very encouraging now
this is not to single out Amazon or
United or or Atlas this kind of
diversity hiring is endemic in the
aviation industry Keenan says that she's
received several messages from Pilots
warning her of uh of this danger in
recent days so here's one uh Anonymous
message that she posted
quote every airline has an informal
pilot assignment program that makes sure
their unfireable Dei problem children
are always paired with adult supervision
these program are maintained by aging
Boomers who are immune to the Kool-Aid
as these guys retire every flight will
be a roll of the
dice now remember back we just talked
about that flight that almost crashed
into the ocean and you had the one
person who didn't know what they were
doing and pressed the wrong button and
then the other guy that's trying to
figure out is that is that one of those
situations was this a babysitting
Mission we don't
know this rampant Dei mandate doesn't
just extend to Airlines either a few
weeks ago on the show when I predicted
that we're due for a major air disaster
soon I talked mainly about Dei based
hiring and air traffic control there's
also a push to diversify the ranks of
companies that manufacture and install
various Airline parts and that includes
companies like Spirit Aeros systems
which is no relation to Spirit Airlines
which manufactured that door that blew
out on the Alaska Airlines flight over
the over Portland the other day uh like
United and Atlas Air spe Aeros systems
website is full of Dei propaganda in
fact just days before the door blew out
on the plane Spirit Executives were
posting eagerly on LinkedIn about their
next big diversity event meanwhile the
company knew they had more serious
problems shortly before the door fell
off of a passenger plane mid-flight
Spirit Aeros systems was hit with a
class action lawsuit in federal court
and in the lawsuit investors alleged
that Spirit was aware of the systemic
defects in their products but ignored
them and falsified documents to hide
them in one instance the law alleg quote
Auditors repeatedly found torque
wrenches in mechanics toolboxes that
were not properly calibrated this was a
potentially serious problem as a torque
wrench that is out of calibration may
not torque Fasteners to the correct
levels resulting in overtightening or
under tightening that could threaten the
structal Integrity of the parts in
question but the mechanics didn't want
to comply with the audit according to
the lawsuit quote some mechanics would
not even let Auditors take such outof
calibration tools locking toolboxes or
yanking them back out of the auditor's
hands to Prov V the audit now obviously
these accusations are even remotely true
they reveal some very concerning
problems at a company that makes
critical components for the planes that
you are flying in so how did things get
so bad well it turns out that according
to the lawsuit Spirit fired roughly 50%
of its Workforce in response to the
covid lockdowns they terminated many
experienced mechanics quote unquote in
response to The Economic Consequences of
those shutdowns according to the suit
well when they were doing that how did
Spirit decide who to retain after these
unnecessary lockdowns how did they
decide who to hire after the lockdowns
ended why did they keep the engineers
who apparently don't understand how to
calibrate their torque
wrenches if you take Spirit AOS systems
at its word they probably hired a bunch
of diverse mechanics that's what all
their marketing materials and investor
pitches
dictate but the truth is at this point
we can't be more specific than that is
it possible that a crack team of
mechanics manufacture the doors on all
of these United and Alaska
airplanes as of now yes it is maybe the
fault lies not with Spirit but with
Boeing which has been in Decline ever
since it made the decision to Outsource
key elements of its business to overseas
programmers and Penny Pinchers in
Chicago maybe Boeing installed the door
improperly we don't know but at a
certain point we're entitled to some
answers we shouldn't have to guess or
speculate about about this we should
know the qualifications and the
identities of the people manufacturing
and installing these airplane doors just
like we should know the qualifications
and identities of of the United pilots
who are skimming the water with Boeing
passenger
Jets we shouldn't have any doubts about
their
competence you know we're the ones who
just funded the bailouts for all these
companies we're the ones risking Our
Lives when we board these planes and yes
the situation is that dire last night I
put out a general invitation to um
commercial airline pilots to message me
anonymously if they prefer which of
course most of them do to tell me their
firsthand experience of how Dei is
impacting their profession and I'm still
going through all the messages I
received a lot of them a
lot but what I can tell you is that as I
sit here today after reading everything
that I've read I am not at all eager to
ever board a plane again I mean the
airline industry is in the process of
actively making itself less competent
and less reliable and the pilots
themselves will tell you that if they're
in an environment where they can say
without getting
fired when it comes to the pilots you
know the the old guard the masters of
their profession who were hired and
promoted based on their skill alone they
are still mostly in control but but that
is
changing and meanwhile the airline
industry is hiding the truth and lying
about the dangers we
face like the covid cultist who wrecked
the economy the Dei cultist desperately
don't want you thinking about the
downstream effects of their
ideology and as a result every time an
airplane takes off in this country we
are getting closer and closer to
discovering those Downstream effects the
hard way thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts